[Music]  mom sorry  okay while this delete you're not  clicked on it  what do you mean about you don't it's  not clicked on  our person is very nice I asked the  secret to a successful hi Susan  no look sorry mom I'm on the phone oh no  dad I'm on the phone I'm dead get him  off the foot dad get off the phone what  did you type in well I'm technically  what your password is ha honey are you  all right BYE MOM  you've been in there an awful long time  I'm fine  you're not you'd City needs a proper  cheer that's himself tiny fine officers  I'm going now have something else  [Music]  there what did you do  I clicked on it okay how is that  different than what I was good on it do  what you're gonna do okay  don't delete anymore just they okay  first of all tone chat  [Music]